hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational I thought I'd go a
bit easy with the uploads today but it's
like the it's like they're playing these
crazy games just just so I would show
them on the channel I mean they already
Game one between cars and ending and
already quite quite the treat so without
further ado let's just check it out as
ding with the white pieces opens with
efore and Magnus goes for Knight to c6
he goes for the names of its defense we
have Knight to f3 binding and here
d5 just basically transposing into the
Scandinavian captures captures in the
now Knight to c3 kicking away the Queen
and now Magnus goes for Queen to a5 and
here d4 so Magnus goes Bishop to g4 he
wants to Castle queenside and and
develop his pieces as soon as possible
we have Bishop to b5 now threatening to
ruin Magnus is Queen side but Magnus
just castles Queen side he says I don't
mind this and okay being of course
captures this with Bishop captures will
be captures and c6 and now h3 pushing
the bishop back but now Magnus goes
Queen to h5 now of course captures isn't
allowed because of characters and the
Bishop to e3 now ding will also develop
the Queen and Castle queenside we have
Knight to f6 biting in the Queen to e2
now preparing a castles Queen side and
here there is one game in the database
working to be someone was played but
here we have Bishop captures on f3 and
it's a new move in the position so
already as of move 10 now we have a
completely new game ending of course
captures with the Jeep on he wants the
the Queen's to remain on board we have
east 6 preparing to develop the dark
square Bishop and now the castles Queen
side we have King Tubby 7 by Magnus the
king will be somewhat safer there and
now comes route H to g1 and not allowing
the dark square Bishop to develop so
Magnus goes h6 he wants them develop it
by going g5 so you don't have any
targets here on the Kings side and here
are very nice route lift by dink rook to
d3 and all the point is when the knight
moves you want to play rook to b3 check
you want to bring the Queen over to a5
and you want to start an attack
against Carlson's king so here we have
looked the g8 and now preparing g5 and
now Knight to e4 biting saying that okay
I have a great night here I'm gonna play
Ruby three a queen day a six check and
so on so Bishop to e7 calls and says I'm
not I'm not very impressed by this we
have looked the b3 check King goes to
see it and now Queen to a6 check and now
Carson just goes King to d7 he says I'm
just gonna run away this way and here
ding prepares with rook to d1 however I
will mention it but it's it's really
it's it's really not possible for a
human to calculate this in such short
time but the d5 is winning here for
white and it's it's just because it's
impossible to capture because if Queen
captures then rook to d1 just wins the
Queen if you try something like C
characters then Queen to a4 check will
just win you the game king goes let's
say here now Bishop captures on a 7-hour
followed by rook to b8 as the Queen
still covers d7 and there are a lot of
other interesting options for example if
eke actress and undie 5 then you get
rook the c3 but this is just it's hard
to give up the d5 point like that if you
don't know what's happening here so just
the the c6 pawn is under attack and
there is no there is no good reply here
you cannot defend it and not not much to
do of course if Knight if the knight is
captured the nen Queen captures and c6
is is just game over for example
captures and then Queen captures and c6
you have kink to see it and now of
course just Queen captures on c7 is mate
and there are a lot of very interesting
options after 85 you can go rook the c3
like we mentioned Bishop d6 you give up
the pawn here with check King g7 and now
Knight captures on d6 for example C
capture son d6 in our Bishop Tadros on a
7 and you have this well very weird
position but but white is much better
and of course winning it just the two
connected fast pawns here are enough but
not to even count that black has a king
on e7 in a wide-open board but instead
of d5 ding first goes for rook to d1 he
prepares it but now Carlsen first
captures on f3
we have Queen captures on f3 and now
Knight to D to a degree maneuvers the
night while attacking the Queen he wants
to bring it the c4 and then to e5 so
Magnus grabs yet another pawn and now
it's nice to see four I'm going for a
knight to the e5 check so cost and
starts running away with the King King
t8 and now Knight to e5 as planned
preparing to capture on c6 we have
Bishop to d6 and now comes the first
Knight captures and c6 of course you
grab the pawn attack the rook rook to e8
and now Queen to b7 again going for the
rook we have king - b7 by Magnus and now
the king is at once again in the in the
middle of the board we have nice to e5
check now hoping for characters capture
so you open up in the D file for the
rook so pink the e7 by Magnus and now
being finds the very interesting Bishop
to f4 you open up an attack against the
Queen here and also there's a there will
be a discovery here against the
DeBusschere
so Queen to five you have to move the
Queen somewhere and the now comes Knight
to c6 width check again if the King goes
anywhere along the eighth-ranked you
just grab the look with check so King
the d7 by Magnus but here to here just
Bishop captures on d6 we have King
Capra's on d6 and now Knight to e5 and
here the Magnus doesn't doesn't really
have a good move he tried the Queen to
f4 but with check King Tubby one and now
rook jitta f8 but it was also in this
position that Magnus calls and resigned
the game so he defended his f7 pawn from
from characters with check but there is
now a force to checkmate here so even if
you want your even welcome to pause the
video and try to find this mating
pattern while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
the D forced mate in five and again when
I say mate in five I mean mate in five
with the absolute best defense
so of course black and play lesser moves
and get checkmate it sooner so here it's
of course Queen to b4 with chat not
Quinta Queen to c6 check then you allow
the King to escape here so Queen to b4
check a way of King to d5 or or you
you can block with Seif oven than just
Queen captures on c5 mates so King has
to go to d5 and now a nice nice little
improvement in the position f3 just not
allowing this efore squared to the king
and next move whatever black plays c-4
is mate so it's it's a bit less than
five moves but why a black can't prolong
and that's why you have to say It's Made
in five you can go Quincy one check so
and then make another move and then
along with silly moves but in normal
terms whatever you play c4 is made so
after rook gf8 cross and resigns and
yeah brilliant victory for ding in round
one and since it doesn't really matter
for Magnus or ding who wins this match
as they are both into the go into the
going into the playoffs and a knockout
stage of the tournament
I guess Magnus again decided to have
some fun yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Adam Godby Todd Kissel Erica Shen and
Michael Davis and Matthew garand for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video Sarah
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continue the coverage of the
Magnus invitational until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you and have an
excellent rest of your day